Dragon Ball GT versus Dragon Ball super
which is a better series okay so a
little bit of context first for those of
you here that are new ever since I
started this channel way back in 2015
I've had something of a running joke
where I bleep out the GT in Dragon Ball
GT sort of like that to say mini GT fans
didn't like that and began sounding off
in the comments time and again now this
was mostly a joke but they were right to
some extent while it was a joke it was
also rooted in a real negative feeling I
had four GT while it was on the air I
genuinely thought it ruined my favorite
TV show but keep in mind I was also 12
years old when I said this I was a
little dramatic so much so I actually
gave up around episode 14 never to look
back at the series ever again or so I
thought fast-forward to January 2020 I
had just finished up reviewing the films
of Dragon Balls past and present and was
just about ready to get back to
normality and that was when I noticed
more comets much more than there ever
had been in the past cropping up on
YouTube and Twitter asking me to finally
review Dragon Ball GT and that was when
I had an idea what if I reviewed Dragon
Ball GT and Dragon Ball super ending on
one big final review where I decided
once and for all which one it was that I
preferred fast forward another few
months and many many many reviews later
it brings us to today's video a video I
wanted to make for quite a while what
I've waited to deliver on and one I am
now ready to tackle and write today I
will be analyzing which series I think
works better as a Dragon Ball story and
what I believe to be the superior sequel
1996 is Dragon Ball GT or 2015's Dragon
Ball super let's find out
[Music]
okay so first off right from the top I
want to say that what I loved and liked
about Dragon Ball will obviously inform
the decisions made at the end and
throughout this video
therefore if the things you like about
Dragon Ball are different to mine
chances are you will disagree in some
shape or form with this video's
conclusion and that is totally okay with
that said I will try to not make blanket
meaningless statements any decision I do
come to or claim I make I will try to
explain my answer and back up my
thinking with examples and reasoning as
best I can and so let's start with our
first question which series had the
better start I think it should go
without saying that this section could
very easily be retitled to which one had
the least bad first dark but let's take
a closer look first Dragon Ball super is
first dark absolutely had its upsides I
thought it did a decent job in
establishing the key characters Goku
Vegeta Wiese and beerus as they go about
their lives and eventually come into
conflict with each other
additionally there's at times some
decent humor in the arc and on top of
all of that the fight with beerus in
certain episodes felt distinctly more
fun and enjoyable to me when compared to
the movie and mangas interpretations
delving deeper and exploring more into
the dynamic of goku and beerus however
that's part of this arcs largest issue
it is a remake of a pre-existing film
Dragon Ball Z battle of gods was
released in 2012 and the Dragon Ball
super battle of gods was created in 2015
which translated to the vast majority of
people initially watching the show being
very familiar with the story being told
already despite the minor changes to it
here and there
additionally due to crippling time
restraints the animation staff at OE
were given so little time to actually
create this arc that the animation
produced and a lot of these first
episodes was tragic to say the least
despite these substantial issues the
final fight with beerus was largely
absent of all of these transgressions on
the flip side of that the first two
episodes of Dragon Ball GT did a
fantastic job in setting up the plot
quickly and establishing the key
character's personality circumstances
and motivations for the coming adventure
pan specifically had some fantastic
introductions to her story probably the
strongest of all the introductions
between these two series so far
additionally the entire first arc and
subsequent arcs of Dragon Ball GT are
entirely unique
upon airing this story had never before
been seen in either movie norm on which
in my opinion as to the suspense and
mystery of the narrative assuming that's
what they actually wanted to achieve
with it what's more is that since the
show started right after the completion
of Dragon Ball Z the staff in charge of
the animation and overall aesthetic
largely remained consistent which meant
Dragon Ball GT remained visually good
and compatible with Z throughout its
first Park however with that said I
really really didn't like Dragon Ball GT
s first arc and what I mean by that is I
hated Dragon Ball GT his first part with
a passion that burns probably dude
building swords no point did it even
come close to something I could even
pretend I was interested in the first
arc of Dragon Ball GT might have even
been my least favorite anything I've
ever watched in Dragonball except friend
had it not been for that award episode
towards the end of the arc that centered
around Buda Orgill and pan in the desert
I don't know what I would have done but
I did actually like that one episode
probably because it wasn't connect to
the story of the show's first arc in any
way whatsoever I know I did mention
earlier that's something that could have
stood in its favour was that it was
telling a unique story and that is true
but I would rather watch a bad retelling
of an average story over watching a
confused telling of what is to me a
terrible story thankfully though things
pick up and change rather radically at
this point in GT but it's too little too
late the visuals look good for GT the
first two episodes did a lot right but
these aspects aren't enough to save it
from what is to me an uncompromising ly
boring first arc and so I got to give
super the better opening to the story
despite it not being anything new and
the visuals a lot of the time melting
before my eyes it never was quite as
boring as GTS first and the instances of
enjoyment I found within supers first
arc far outnumber that of GTS first for
me which has better action
i deliberated over this particular
section for quite a while not because
the answer wasn't obvious to me but
because I wanted to make sure I was
covering all my bases the quality of a
particular shows action especially a 2d
animated series as action leans heavily
on the quality of its animation overall
direction the direction includes things
like storyboarding and overall
composition of shots it may not seem too
important to some of you but shot
composition is the difference between
making a fight live boring or thrilling
shot composition and editing
specifically is what makes editors like
Edgar Wright as successful as they are
and what makes animated sequences like
those from no Toshi schita look as
incredible as they do yes it looks
cooled but have you ever thought about
what makes it look cool it's the overly
exaggerated angles massive expressions
and timing of the sequences knowing when
to make a close up and went to swoop to
a medium and long shot all the while
keeping in mind the context of the scene
and integrity of the characters there's
tons to consider when talking about the
visuals of an action scene that even
that's ignoring the narrative element of
an action scene which to me is one of
the most important components in making
them compelling Dragon Ball GT as I
mentioned earlier is easily the more
visually consistent out of the two and
Dragon Ball super really felt like it
was barely treading water in that
department for the first 40% of the
series I draw attention to all of these
variables because I want you all to know
that coming to this decision wasn't
something I didn't think about long and
hard over but I have come to a decision
Dragon Ball super for me without
reservation has the better more
interesting action sequences I say this
not because I think the animation in
Dragon Ball GT is action sequences were
sipar or that Dragon Ball GT didn't have
some spectacular action sequences but
thinking back on my time watching the
two series not a single fight in the
first arc of GT stands out to me the
Super 17 fight I personally found
excessively blend and uninteresting and
I have similar feelings towards the
majority of the Shadow Dragon saga with
that said I did love a lot of the action
provided by the baby Saga Goku's fight
with general arundo baby Gohan versus
Vegeta as well as some action scenes
with Goten we're really interesting to
me but
and then I didn't really enjoy the final
battle with baby as again it all looked
very safe and for the most part fighting
a giant monkey gets really stale very
fast
additionally there wasn't too much
interesting in the way of animation
visual direction or even narrative
direction the most memorable shock to me
from the entire series however has to be
the Spirit Bomb at the very very end the
color employed and how it's drawn just
feels so satisfying to look at and it's
literally the only instance from GT I
have in my spare time decided to look up
for fun keeping all of that in mind when
I think about Dragon Ball super I could
think of a number of compelling action
moments Goku's fight with beerus in
episodes 11 and 14 Goku and Vegeta's
training with Wiese Goku vs frost Goku
vs hit Vegeta vs. Cobham Bogata and his
trunks versus black vegeta vs fuse the
massive Frieza versus topo Goku versus
journey I could easily go on the sheer
level of quality and variety and some of
these is honestly spectacular to me
Dragon Ball super despite having a rough
start when it came to the animation as
the series progressed the highest
heights the series would reach visually
superseded any episode of Dragon Ball GT
and I would even argue Dragon Ball Z
episode 130 of Dragon Ball super has
more impressive movement and animation
than any other single episode in the
entire franchise on top of all of this
best fights within Super have left a
lasting impression on me unlike the best
of Dragon Ball GT s naturally however
that could largely be down to me being
exposed to one product more than the
other and that's a very fair argument
but I can't really control for that
however one thing that plays into the
success of a particular fight scene for
many of us is how effective a particular
stories our antagonists are so for the
next section let's discuss Dragon Ball
GT s and supers villains and antagonists
which series were better
but like the previous section I thought
this one was going to be a cakewalk for
Dragon Ball super but after going back
over the series while there are more
antagonist I enjoyed the GT in Super I
think GT has a very good argument for
having the best antagonist when looking
at the two series side by side while I
really didn't like super 17 and didn't
enjoy the shadow dragons and well lude
makes me want to eat my own face baby is
very much a fantastic diamond amidst a
sea of rough patches but what's more is
that when taking stock of the antagonist
within Dragon Ball super there really
was only one name that came up to
challenge baby for me not hit not Frieza
and definitely not jiren Goku black and
while I could easily choose to includes
Omashu in this equation with Goku black
I've said in the past that Zuma soo I
think is distinctly different to black
in how he acts and talks at a lot of the
time and so I've decided to go for the
stronger character of the two in this
instance so who's a better antagonist
baby or Goku black well right off the
bat baby is a really creative concept
and Goku black well let's be honest
isn't the idea of an evil Goku looks to
be on a cursory glance overly simplistic
and uninspired also the appearance of
him isn't foreshadowed or anything like
that in a prior arc he just sort of
comes out of nowhere as something
entirely new which makes it feel very
tagged on and post rather than something
that was premeditated and planned for I
mean this in speaking about the concept
not in practice I'll talk about that in
a second on the flipside gt's baby
character legitimately feels unnerving
to me and while it does feel like a
derivative of both you and Sal combined
the concept of a TOEFL engineered
parasite that wishes to take revenge of
the sands that took over their world is
not only creative but extremely well
integrated and most importantly
believable within the new continuity
making it once again feel like much more
of a larger story rather than a
segmented one with that said I think the
dialogue scenes black takes pardon
really steal the show for me what I see
from his grand reveal all the way
through him revealing more information
about his origin through his tormenting
of trucks he is definitely the character
that possesses the more charisma of the
two baby isn't bad but he very much felt
like all the most generic parts of a
Dragonball Z villain what he spoke so
taking that into consideration it all
depends on which one you feel carries
the more weight I'm honestly sort of
undecided both have their ups and their
downs sides but one thing I will say is
that I very much disliked what baby's
final transformation turned out to be in
GT whereas in Super I very much
thoroughly light how fused the ma suit
turned out in all his easy purple glory
in addition to all of this both of these
forms are fantastic for the visual
storytelling and neither get the
appreciation they deserve so I'm gonna
do that right now the giant ape baby
becomes and the crazed monster black and
Samus to become our perfect
representations and physical
manifestations of their negative arc
spiraling out of control in other words
these forms create instances where these
antagonists become exactly what they
hated in the case of Goku black he
becomes not a divine beautiful perfect
entity but a crazed gruesome ugly maniac
bent on destroying life itself and with
baby he was designed to be the answer to
the evil Saiyans that wrongly conquered
their worlds but ended up being exactly
what he was designed to protect others
from a monstrous alien force that aims
to crush a land that is not his own I
love this about both of these characters
and while I don't like aspects from both
- I think Goku black salt with the feet
when he sliced by Trump's ass or it
looks more visually interesting than
what GT did and while I know it makes no
sense for Trump's to do that there were
plenty of instances in the finish -
baby's ultimate defeat that didn't make
sense either and didn't look nearly as
interesting but then again the Goku
black arc has the worst ending in the
entire series this is honestly the
toughest decision I've made so far both
are great in different aspects and awful
and others but in the interest of being
fair I think right now baby as an
antagonist offered a lot of opportunity
to create unique encounters in the arc
he led the charge for and was most
certainly used effectively for the
majority of the air and what I think
Goku black offered a lot of that - I
think what baby offered was much more
unique and inspired in comparison
was hurt let's do something a little
more easy now something a little lighter
something I'm sure won't lead to a
massive argument in the comment section
let's talk about which show had the
better music I want the record to show
that before I get into this I love both
the scores from Dragon Ball GT and
Dragon Ball super
while supers music left a lot to be
desired early on in the series for the
exact same breezes the animation
suffered early on as the series began
progressing further into the story it
very much found its footing in the
latter half of the series with tracks
and various motifs surrounding the
second dopey as my personal favorites
and the always impactful Super Saiyan
blue feet but despite loving the tracks
in the latter half of the Sumitomo
Dragon Ball super catalog I cannot seem
to get around my clear preference for
what Dragon Ball GT offered in the way
of music the variety of it as well as
the gorgeous flutes and trumpets offer a
natural yet distinct continuation to the
original Kikuchi Dragon Ball score and
that's not even talking about GTS theme
song I know I'm not talking about I'm
talking about this the various light
motifs surrounding this particular piece
of music which the show chose to
represent adventure and friendship never
gets old for me culminating at the very
end where it always brings a tear to my
eye it's got this wonderfully nostalgic
quality to it and feels distinctly
Dragon Ball the easy winner of this
section for me goes to Dragon Ball GT
and next up is characterization which
series did more for its characters
Dragon Ball GT actively didn't do a
single thing with any of its characters
in terms of character development
wouldn't obvious glaring candidate for a
potential character actress if Ian's
program was pan penned is a tough
headstrong but naive girl who was
begging to develop into a more complete
vision of the character that gains an
appreciation for what it really takes to
be a true hero of the earth like her
grandpa and to earn the respect of her
family and friends in the process but
noob gotta throw all that out the window
so that she can cause Goku problems in
the story because nothing in the show
could possibly fulfill that particular
writing necessity for them oh wait
in place of pet and Dragon Ball super
has stupid super Goku where he will
actively antagonize individuals that
won't give him attention and will forget
crucial parts of the game plan just to
create artificial tension for a scene
because the writers couldn't come up
with anything a little more creative I
think it's safe to say that both have
their own low points and disappointments
in this particular section but alas I
have to choose one Dragon Ball GT
introduces very few new characters I
suppose we are reintroduced in some way
to individuals like trunks and goten but
really they both do very little in the
story in the case of trumps I found him
to be pretty bland and only there
essentially to drive Goku around the
place and make tech magic happen at
least when Bulma did it she was an
active character with agency whereas
trunks is very much a quiet reserves
nothing character that reacts to things
happening to him rather than him causing
the plot to happen the only recurring
new character really was butyl and while
I really liked him later in the show he
is but a small flickering light amidst
an ocean of darkness another character I
enjoyed far more than I thought I would
in GT was goat in his lady killer
persona is a strangely great fit for him
and I was interested to see more from
and beyond the brief glimpse as we ended
up getting but surprise surprise we got
nothing more unfortunately I have to
give this section to Dragon Ball super
because they at the very least tried to
deliver moments that eventually led to
something for their respective
characters GT didn't even really try the
instances where we got to see Vegeta
training Kaba or the ridiculously fast
minor development Gohan got to
experience the tournament of power
led to some wonderful interactions in
the endgame on top of all of that the
conversations Frieza participated in
from before his involvement in the
tournament all the way through to his
conclusion are not only highlights in
this series of super but also the entire
Dragon Ball franchise for me so
surprisingly and so much disappointingly
with ease I assert that Dragon Ball
super did more for its characters than
GTD and so on to the next section which
works better as a story continuation
there's two ways of interpreting this
question should I look at how the arcs
of the given series informed and created
the foundation for subsequent arcs or
should I look at the difference in the
story created for its meta-narrative as
it progressed but before I discuss that
I want to mention something that I'm
sure will be brought up in the comments
section the fact that Dragon Ball super
had two arcs centered around tournaments
will not be something I'll hold against
the series the original Dragon Ball TV
show ran for a hundred and fifty three
episodes and three of the acts were
based around tournaments and so I wanted
to be clear that I'm not holding Dragon
Ball super to any special standard other
than what I would hold the rest of the
series to Dragon Ball happens to have a
long history of tournament arcs and I
enjoy all of them for one reason or
another but I digress
what do I think to be a better
continuation of the story well this is
difficult simply because the story each
series attempts to tell occupies a
different area of the Dragon Ball
timeline GT takes place long after the
events of Dragon Ball Z's end with Goku
confronted at the world tournament and
super takes up right after the events of
the Buu sagas finish attempting to fill
in the missing portion of the timeline
between the Buu arc and end of Z then
right off the bat I have massive issues
with the approach both of these series
have taken and substantial pros in favor
of each one also firstly Dragon Ball
super I thought did a much better job at
continuing the tone of Dragon Ball Z
into its telling before eventually
establishing its own voice gradually
along the way whereas the segmented
disjointed nature of its arcs really
left a lot to be desired regarding this
particular topic in Dragon Ball GT the
first act informs the events of the
second and the third informs the events
of the final there were substantial
efforts made during gt's development to
tie the events of GT together to make it
feel like a larger more grand tale this
is the same philosophy implemented in
the arcs of Z like the say anomic and
Android arcs however in saying that
Dragon Ball
GT despite having a direct continuation
to Dragonball Z in 1996 is an entirely
different type of show right off the bat
while yes the original run of Dragonball
is centered around adventure and
somewhat episodic storytelling it also
wasn't burdened by having to follow up
and continue off of anything else and so
while the Saiyan saga of Dragonball Z is
distinctly different to the beginning of
Dragonball it wasn't a jarring shift in
focus because they had spent two prior
arcs dealing with subjects and
circumstances that allowed the shift to
feel far more natural nothing about
going from the end of Z to GT felt
natural for me personally just an
extremely jarring toll shift and so
despite me really disliking ho Dragon
Ball super did fire fire a little in
comparison to GT and Titan there arcs
together I personally found super to be
a far less jarring experience when going
from Z to Dragon Ball super and that
brings us to the final segment which
series delivered the better ending this
speed the section I actually spent the
most time as I sort of kept going back
and forth but in the end finally had to
make a decision
both of these intellectual properties
have incredibly strong but very
different approaches to how they
conclude their respective series and I
love both of these final episodes but
for vastly different reasons
first off I can hear some of you already
claiming that Dragon Ball super is
ending isn't really a definitive one and
to that I say right now the series is
over Dragon Ball Z didn't have a
definitive ending per se either and so
really having a definitive ending is
entirely a unique thing to GT again I
would still claim that Z has an ending
as I would super so how do they differ
well GT provided a lot of closure
wrapping up the meaningful relationships
Goku built up over his life concluding
in a tear-jerking send-off as he watches
his descendants battle in a world
tournament before walking off and being
greeted by a montage of the best moments
in the series Dragon Ball super on the
other hand provided us with an
incredibly action-packed emotional
conclusion to what the arc and series
itself had built up to while giving us a
somewhat lesser emotional send-off
before sprinkly on some nostalgia at the
end and saying goodbye keeping both of
these wonderful endings in mind which
worked better as an ending to their
respective series for me Dragon Ball
super did
now here Mia I absolutely adore what
they did with Dragon Ball GT is ending
I've probably seen it hundreds of times
in one form or another but supers finale
works as well as it does because of
super storytelling
whereas GTS finale works as well as it
does because of Dragon Ball Z and
absolutely not because of Dragon Ball GT
so why do I think this well Dragon Ball
GT is final episodes centers around
emotional send offs Vegeta piccolo and
krillen all receive emotional farewells
to Goku during these goodbyes no one is
thinking of anything meaningful GT
contributed to their relationships with
Goku as those instances didn't really
happen in GT and that's not even a
controversial thing for me to say as
none of these characters despite being
meaningful to Goku played virtually any
role in the entire series of Dragon Ball
GT and because no new meaningful
relationships had been established
between Goku and anyone else in GT when
it came time to allocate and structure
character scenes for the ending the
options were obvious additionally the
final montage that ends the series is
top-to-bottom original Dragon Ball with
very little GT almost as if they didn't
want to lean into the fact that GT
existed to me this looked as though they
were trying to make themselves feel like
the natural continuation to the series
yet as I established earlier the shift
in tone and what the series was trying
to go for from the very beginning was
incredibly distinct to Dragon Ball Z in
this particular section super takes it
because it delivered an incredibly
effective ending that couldn't have
existed without Dragon Ball super
whereas Dragon Ball GT ending was
specifically designed prior to the
series as creation as revealed by the
Dragon Ball GT producers meaning it
relied not on its own merits to be
effective but the writing of another
better series in the original Dragon
Ball over the last several months I have
taken the time to clearly illuminate my
likes and dislikes with regards these
two series both have their substantial
ups and downs and both are incredibly
different the explanations i've given
today could very easily be arguments for
Dragon Ball GT for another individual
however in my personal opinion Dragon
Ball super feels to me like the stronger
of the two shows for the many reasons I
outlined today and over the last several
months
I have many issues with both of these
series as I'm sure
a lot of you out there do too or perhaps
you don't then love them both equally
either way whatever your position maybe
should be the only thing that matters to
you and with that said I hope you found
this video to be entertaining and worth
the wait I seriously tried my best to be
as upfront and clear about my thought
process as I possibly could and I hope I
met your expectations but that will do
it for this week I hope you had fun and
thank you so much for watching a lot see
you next week
[Music]